welcome to exploring computing
today's video is bliss and loops
so one thing that computers are really
good at is processing lists of
information and this is both because
we don't really like processing large
amounts of information let's say we need
to do a calculation on a single stanford
student like maybe we're doing
graduation check on a single stanford
student that doesn't sound too bad but
then we go well we want you to do this
graduation check on 12 000 stanford
students that's sounding
like not a lot of fun so
computers on the other hand don't care
how many items there are
and they're really good at carrying out
the exact same calculation on each of
the different
people in a list or each of the
different bank accounts on a list
or each of the different whatever you
have in the list so lists are
super common when processing information
on the computer and computers are
great at processing lots of information
all right so
here we're creating several different
lists of information
i've got a list of ages and i've got a
list of
team members you can see in each case
the way i'm going to do this is i'm
going to have that
square bracket followed by a number of
items separated by commas followed by a
closing square bracket and that's going
to go ahead and create my list and i can
go ahead and store a list in a variable
so i store my list of ages into the ages
variable i store my list of names in the
team members variable
so another thing that you might run into
is the empty list
the empty list is a list with no items
in it and uh so this is
an empty list here i'm going to start my
course list i don't have it signed up
for any courses yet
so i've got an open square bracket
followed by a closed square bracket and
that indicates that i do have a list
that list is there it's available for me
to put classes in but i don't have any
classes in it yet
we can access individual items in a list
using a
another square bracket notation if i
have the name of a list
followed by square bracket followed by
the particular index number of the item
in the list that i want to access
this will allow me to access a an item
in the list
so in this case i'm accessing the number
two item in my team member list now
you might think that that's going to be
hank but actually it isn't because it
turns out that
python and many other programming
languages but it turns out not all
programming languages thanks guys
start numbering lists with zero so in
this case
kc will be item zero hank will be item
one
and tammy will be item two so this will
actually print the string tammy
we can also use this format uh this
square bracket format to
change items in the list so if i say
team members
bracket one again uh we've got casey's
item zero hank's number one and so
now what i'm actually doing is i'm
assigning into team members
won so i'm assigning into the location
that hank is currently occupying and
this actually does not
insert this new team member this
actually replaces this current team
member so
hank is going to be replaced by joe here
can add items onto the end of an
existing list by using the append
this uses a slightly different syntax
than we've seen before so here i've got
the course list with the original
empty list that we sell that example a
couple minutes ago
and then i use course list dot append so
i
i take the name of a variable which is
storing the list i follow it by the
period or the dot
followed by append and so the
implication here is that
i'm going to append the list and the
list that i'm going to append to is the
list which pre-sees that period so in
this case i'm
adding to the course list so it seems
like a bit of a
difference from what we've seen before
um
as you'll discover in a minute they kind
of mix up
uh when to use this format and want to
use the
previous format that we've been using i
think it's a little bit confusing but
that's the way python defined it looks
like okay so course underscore list
dot append meaning i'm appending to the
course list
and then i go ahead and append cs105 i
can append ihem 6a i can append
econ 1a and so the end result after
running these four lines of code will be
i have a list with three classes in it
tis 105
i ham 6a and econ 1a
[Music]
the append only allows you to add to the
end of the list there is a fancier
insert that you can use if you want to
put items in the middle list but you
won't need it for our class so i'm just
going to go ahead and skip it
now sometimes you're going to want to
know how long the list is and so you can
determine how long the list is by taking
the length
so i'm going to take len short for
length
i'm going to have a pair of parentheses
and i'm going to pass in the list
pass in a variable that's storing a list
and it will return a number so in this
particular case
since my list had three courses in it
this will print i am taking
three classes all right one of the most
common things that we'll want to do with
lists is to process the items in the
list
and we're going to do that using a for
loop control structure so just as a
reminder
a control structure allows us to control
when statements get executed
and sometimes how many times they get
executed the conditional control
structure which we saw last lecture
executes some statements when a
condition is true and potentially
it will also execute another set of
statements when that condition is false
so we took a look at the if statement
the if else statement and chained if
else statements
last lecture the loop control structure
will allow us to execute the same code
over and over and over again and there
are several different versions of this
the simplest one executes the code over
and over again for all the items in a
list
you can also execute the same code over
and over again for a set number of times
and you may also execute the same code
over and over again until a particular
condition is true we're just going to
take a look at that first one
it's the most straightforward it's
pretty easy to use and
it's very useful all right so
here's our first example of a for loop
um i'm going to print out
each of the classes that i'm taking and
so
the way this works is i create a new
variable in the for loop in this case
the variable's course
and what's going to happen here is that
course will be set to
different values one for each of the
values in my
second variable here course list which i
previously set and we saw a little bit
earlier that's the list that i appended
a bunch of
different items to and so
what will happen is the statements in
the for loop
which in this case is the print i am
taking course
will get executed one at a time for each
of the different values
of the course list
all right so let's take a look at this
running in action so here's my
original course list previously i added
all the items to it or
this time we're just going to assume
that it's already initially pre-defined
so
there's my course list and uh here's my
little for loop here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to perform
different what are referred to as
iterations of the loop and so an
iteration of loop means
we're going back and executing the
statements in the for loop again and
again and again so each of those would
be different iterations so in the first
iteration
uh what's going to happen here is that
the course
variable which is set in the for loop is
going to get set initially to cs105
and then i'm going to print i am taking
cs105
and then the second iteration of the
loop i'm going to go back up
and i'm going to reset the value of the
course variable
to ihum 6a
and then i'm going to execute the
statement print
and in this case it's going to do the
equivalent of printing i am taking
and then uh it'll retrieve the value of
the variable so it'll be as if i had
that
string there ihon6a there and it'll
print i am taking
i am 6a and then uh we've got one more
iteration the third iteration
uh the course is going to be set to econ
1a
and uh this will print i am taking econ
and there's my output so it did exactly
what we expected
now you can kind of think of this loop
as being the equivalent of
uh the non-loop version print i'm taking
cs105 print i am taking im 6a
print i am taking econ 1a but
because we're doing this in a for loop
we have a lot more flexibility we can
change all the items in the list
and it will automatically change the
number of times it's printing so
the loops are super useful and very
important when we're working with lists
of items
so let's take a quick look at the syntax
of our loops
so we've got that word for and we've got
the word in
and uh and then we've got those colon
that colon at the end of that first line
and so those are all
required and those are going to just be
copied as is
the four in the end you'll recall those
are what we refer to as reserve words or
keywords
um the idea being that this is reserved
for use by the python language and i
can't name a variable four i can't name
a variable in it would give get python
very confused so don't do that
and then i've got the loop variable and
so this is going to be
uh the first time that loop variable is
mentioned and it's going to be used
inside of the loop to
represent the different values in the
next variable which is a list variable
um i should mention that you don't
actually have to have a variable in that
second position after the end
if you want you could actually put a
list directly there
it's much less common usually as a
variable but but it is possible
so here i've replaced the code that we
had previously um
where i refer to the course underscore
list variable and i've just replaced it
by
just right in the list right there and
that is that is doable
okay and then we have our statements and
these are the statements that will get
executed
over and over and over again for each of
the values of our loop variable
um i do want to mention that it is
possible to
have more than one statement so here i'm
i'm printing out two statements i'm
printing out i am taking
and then i print the course name and i'm
also printing
the course is a lot of fun it's also
possible to have statements both before
and
after the for loop um so if you have
statements before the for loop
uh those will get done once before we
enter the loop and if you've got
statements after the for loop those will
get done once
after we finish the for loop and so the
way
that python is going to determine what
is actually repeated over and over and
over again is by the indentation so in
this case here
the print my schedule is that only
happens once
the print i am taking course that
happens over and over and over again
and then they print i may add more later
that's all going to happen once
and the way python can tell the
difference between
the print statement that happens over
and over and over again for each of the
courses versus the one that only happens
once
is that indentation because print i am
taking course
is indented um that's the one that's
subordinate
to the for loop and that's the one that
will get printed over and over and over
again and
again we could add additional statements
that we wanted to carry out over and
over and over again but they would need
to be indented
at the same level as that one that we've
got there
okay let's take a look at something a
bit more complicated so this is a
example where i'm trying to determine if
pizza delivery is available
uh for a particular zip code and so
i'm going to go ahead and come up with a
list of zip codes
and then i'm going to ask the user what
is their zip code
um so we've got our variable here in the
for loop
the zip code variable and that's the one
that's going to have its value changed
so it will be
94301 to start off with then it'll be
94305 and so on and then the statement
in the for loop the ones that are
indented over those will get executed
over and over and over again for each of
the
values in our zip code list
and one thing that you may notice if you
look at this carefully is that
if we run into a zip code in the list
which is the same as the zip code the
user has entered let's say the user
enters in 94305
then we'll print deliveries available
but you may notice if we enter in a zip
code that's not
not there like uh 90210
um that
uh no print statement occurs at all and
basically the user won't see any output
at all and they'll wonder what's going
on so we'll fix that a little bit later
it's actually a little bit complicated
so that'll be the last thing we do this
lecture
but i did want to mention that what
we're going to do now is we're going to
look at a couple more examples of for
loops in action
in this first example we're going to add
all the values on the list so i've got a
list with 100 200 150
400 and i want to know what the total of
all those values is and so
we've got a little for loop we've got
our variable here number
in the for loop4 number in my list and
as you know
number will be set to each of the
different values in our list 100 200 150
and 400 in turn
and then we've got that indented
statement that's going to get executed
once for each of the numbers once for
100 once for 200 once 450 and once for
400.
now that statement there total equals
total plus
number a lot of students find that a bit
confusing because
you know if you kind of think about it
that kind of seems like i'm saying
one equals one plus
one like how can total equal total plus
something else unless number zero so
that's not the right way to be thinking
about it
the right way to be thinking about that
equal sign is not as the thing on the
left is the same as the thing on the
right the way to be thinking about it is
i'm going to carry out the actions on
the right
hand side of the equal sign and i'm
going to store the result of
whatever those actions uh generate
and i'm going to store that into the
variable on the left hand side of the
equal sign so
it's not saying the two are equal when
we start running it
what it's saying is i've got a
calculation on the right i'm going to go
ahead and carry out that calculation and
whatever the result of that is
you know whether or not that calculation
on the right includes the current value
of total or not
i don't really care whatever the result
of that is
i'm going to store that as the new value
of total so in this particular case
total equals total plus number means
retrieve the value of the total variable
right now
add a new add the value of the number
variable
to the current value of the total
variable take the resulting
value of the two of them added together
and store that as the new result
into total so again it's not saying that
total is initially equal to total plus
number
it's saying that um after
carrying out total plus number take the
result of that calculation and then
store it
back into total so you know we do use
the equal sign but
if you're getting confused by it you
might want to think of
it not as an equal sign but as a
operator that says assign
into the variable on the left so assign
into
total whatever the value of carrying out
the calculation total plus
number is all right so let's actually
walk through this
um so we're going to go through our
iterations remember uh iterations
are the name we give to each of the
executions of the statement in our for
loop
so in iteration one the total is
initially zero because i set
total equal to zero before i started my
for loop
um and so total starts off at zero
and uh we start off number as the first
number on the list which is a hundred
so total equals total plus number and
that takes the current value of total
which is zero
takes the current value number which is
100 so total plus number
is a hundred and so after i execute this
whole statement
total's new value will be a hundred
iteration two total is a hundred that's
what
the result from iteration one was and
number is now shifted over to the next
number or list which is 200
so total equals total plus number uh
total is
initially 100 number is 200 so 100 plus
200 it's 300
and so what this is going to do is it's
going to calculate the 300 and then it
will go ahead and store that 300 as the
new value
total okay iteration three
total is now 300 from iteration two
uh numbers now 150 because we've shifted
over to the next item in the list
um total equals total plus number that
gives us 450
um 300 plus 150
and so total's new value would be 450.
and then finally uh from iteration 3
total
is now 450 so when iteration 4 starts
total is a 450.
we add that to number which is 400 so if
i add the initial value of total for
iteration
for 450 plus the new value of number
which is 400 i get 850
and so the total new value is 850 that's
what gets stored back into total
and so when we ask it to print total it
prints the 850.
okay we can go ahead and do an averaging
this is another common operation that we
might want to do with items in the list
and so you can see that the way i'm
going to do this is i'm going to take
the total i'm going to go ahead and
create the total just the same as i did
in the last example by
entering through the list and adding
them all into a total set set the
initial value total to zero
and then go ahead and add each of the
individual items in the list into total
and that's going to get me the 850 we
saw previously
and that what we're going to do is we're
going to take the length of the list
remember the len
function takes a list as a parameter and
uh it returns how long that list is so
in this particular case
uh my list is four has four items in it
so
length my list that's gonna return a
four i'm gonna take the 850
divided by 4 and that's going to print
out 212.5
okay let's go back to our delivery
example so you recall that the problem
with our delivery example is
if the zip code is not found the basic
version doesn't do anything at all so um
that's not good basically if somebody is
in our zip code range it'll print out
hey we can deliver to you
and that'll be fine but if somebody's
not in our zip code range it's not going
to do anything and they're going to
think our
programs bust it so that's that's not
good
all right so what we want to do is we
want to determine whether or not that
print delivery is available
actually occurred and so either that
that statement occurred and we printed
it
or it didn't occur so that's a true
false value and so anytime you've got a
true false value
you should be thinking about booleans
remember a boolean variable is something
that is either true or false
okay so here's my first attempt to fix
it what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go ahead and add in a
statement and notice the statement is
indented at the same level as the print
delivery is available
and i'm going to say zip code found
equals true so what this is going to do
is if we happen to run it a zip code
that is in the list
we're going to print that delivery is
available and we're also going to set
this variable here
zip code found to true so that
that mostly works
but there there's a there's a bit of
problem um and that is
if the print statement doesn't run if
the zip code isn't actually on the list
zip code found is never set um and so
what we really want to do is we want it
to be set to false
if we didn't find it and true if we did
find it and so
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to go ahead and set zip code found
to false
initially before we start our for loop
and then as we go through the for loop
if we happen to run in the zip code
that's great
we'll go ahead and print that delivery
is is available
and at the same time we will reset the
variable
zip code found which is initially false
we'll say okay that would set the false
before but now it's true because
we found your zip code okay so um
that's pretty much it the last thing we
have to do is actually do something
on that basis and so after we
finish this loop either zip code found
is
still at its initial value which is
false which means we didn't run into the
zip code or
we've gone through the list we have
found the zip code we've reset zip code
found from false and it's now set to
true
and then now what we need to do is just
check that value and on that basis
either
you know print sorry no delivery is
available or don't do anything because
we already printed that delivery was
available
so you can see i'm going to take zip
code found
and then you can see i'm inverting the
results so i talked
in the previous lecture about how not
takes the result and flips it so in this
particular case
we don't really care if the zip code is
found what we really want to know if the
zip code was not
found and so putting that not in front
of zip code found actually inverts it so
if zip code found is true not zip code
found is false and i don't do anything
the zip code found is false as it was
initially
not zip code found false is actually
true because again no not does the
inversion and so it prints
sorry no deliveries available so it's a
bit more complicated than what we
started off with but uh this does get us
the result we want
all right that's it for this lecture
we've got a
short uh little video next talking about
a few additional
python language features you might find
handy
you